hola que tal hace minutos finalizó el
cierre de campaña del actual gobernador
del estado miranda y candidato a la
reelección
héctor rodríguez lo acompañó
prácticamente la plana mayor del
gobierno estuvo presente desde el
presidente de la asamblea nacional la
vicepresidenta del país e incluso el
hijo de nicolás maduro cuál es el
discurso llamar a votar para defender la
revolución para condenar las sanciones
impuestas por eeuu a quienes
responsabilizan de la grave crisis en
materia de servicios públicos que vive
el país desde otros puntos de caracas
pero visiblemente desunidos también la
oposición realiza sus cierres de campaña
cuál será el principal reto para ellos
convencer a los votantes de acudir a las
urnas después de cuatro años llamando la
abstención precisamente por la
desconfianza en el consejo nacional
electoral los dirigentes dicen estar
claros que no se trata de una elección
totalmente libre pero aseguran que es
momento de recuperar los espacios y
también para los analistas de renovar
los liderazgos que una posición
visiblemente debilitada ya lo comentaba
está el despliegue de una misión de
observación internacional de la unión
europea que hoy se pronunció ante los
medios de comunicación aseguraron que no
pueden adelantar opiniones que lo harán
el próximo 23 de noviembre pero ya se
desplegaron al interior del país también
hay una pequeña representación del
centro carter y de la organización de
naciones unidas lo que hace diferente
estos comicios pues no pasaba desde hace
15 años